[Music]
the middle east is one of the most
complex regions in the world
currently there are four failing states
and three wars
with major powers increasingly taking
opposite sides
countless armed militias and terrorist
groups are spreading violence across
borders the region has seen conflict
after conflict going back well into the
20th century
but among all the uprisings civil wars
and insurgencies
two countries always seem to be involved
saudi arabia and iran
they're bitter rivals and their feud is
the key to understanding conflicts in
the middle east
the saudis and iranians have never
actually declared war on each other
instead they fight indirectly by
supporting opposing sides in other
countries
and inciting conflicts this is known as
proxy warfare
and it's had a devastating effect on the
region countries especially poor ones
can't function if there are larger
countries pulling strings within their
borders
both the saudis and the iranians see
these civil wars as both
tremendous threats and also potentially
enormous
opportunities the saudi iranian rivalry
has become a fight over
influence and the whole region is a
battlefield it's why the rivalry is
being called
a cold war
[Music]
the most famous cold war was fought for
40 years between the united states and
soviet union
looking forward to the day when their
flag would fly over the entire world
they never declared war on each other
but clashed in proxy wars around the
world
each side supported dictators rebel
groups and intervened in civil wars to
contain the other
like the us and soviet union saudi
arabia and iran are two powerful rivals
but instead of fighting for world
dominance they're fighting over control
of the middle east
in order to understand the saudi iranian
rivalry let's go back to the origins of
each country
[Music]
in the early 1900s the arabian peninsula
was a patchwork of tribes under the
control of the ottoman empire
after world war one the empire collapsed
leaving these tribes to fight each other
over power
one tribe from the interior the al-saad
eventually conquered most of the
peninsula
in 1932 they were recognized as the
kingdom of saudi arabia
six years later massive oil reserves
were discovered in saudi arabia
and in an instant the saudi monarchy was
rich that oil money built roads and
cities all around the desert country
and it helped forge an alliance with the
u.s on the eastern side of the persian
gulf another country was emerging but
having a much harder time
iran also had massive oil reserves and
an even bigger muslim population
but constant foreign intervention was
creating chaos since the 18th century
iran had been invaded by the russians
and the british twice in 1953 the u.s
secretly staged a coup
removing the popular prime minister
mohammad mosaddegh
in his place they propped up a monarch
reza shah who was aggressively reforming
iran into a secular westernized country
but he harbored corruption and
terrorized the population with his
secret police the savak
by the 1970s both saudi arabia and iran
had oil-based economies and had
governments heavily backed by the u.s
but the feelings among each population
were very different ultimately at the
end of the day
the chaveron powerful as he was simply
didn't have the same control over his
people
or ultimately the same legitimacy and
affection
that the saudi people felt toward their
monarchy at that point in time
that's because iran's muslims felt
stifled by the shah's reformations
and by the end of the decade they
finally fought back iran's islamic
revolution overthrew a powerful regime
that boasted military might
it's really in 1979 when ayatollah
khomeini and the islamic revolution
overthrow the shah that the real tension
between iran and saudi arabia began
ayatollah khomeini was a muslim
clergyman
who preached against western-backed
secular monarchies
he advocated for a government that was
popular islamic and led by the clergy
and in 1979 he led a revolution to
establish just that
it was a massive international event
that prompted reactions around the world
especially in saudi arabia the iranian
revolution
terrified the government of saudi arabia
they were fearful that ayatollah
khomeini would inspire their populations
to rise up against them
exactly the way that he had caused the
iranian population
to rise up against the shah and there is
a religious threat too
up until now the saudis had claimed to
be the leaders of the muslim world
largely because islam's two holiest
sites mecca and medina are in saudi
arabia but romani claimed his popular
revolution made iran the legitimate
muslim state and there is another divide
saudi arabia's population is mostly
sunni the majority sect of islam
while romania and iran are mostly shia
westerners always make a mistake
in drawing an analogy between the sunni
shia split
and the protestant catholic split within
christianity the sunni shia split
was never as violent that in much of the
islamic world
when sunnis and shia were living in
close proximity
they got along famously well so while
the sunni shia split was not a reason
for the rivalry
it was an important division after the
revolution the saudis fears came to life
when iran began exporting its revolution
this cia report from 1980 details how
the iranians started helping groups
mostly shia trying to overthrow
governments in iraq afghanistan and
saudi arabia
and they prompted the saudis to redouble
their efforts to fight against iran
they bolstered their alliance with the
u.s and formed the gcc
an alliance with other gulf monarchies
the stage was set for conflict
on september the 22nd iraqi planes
attacked mehrabad airport outside tehran
iraq was gambling on a short sharp
campaign the rise of iran as a regional
power threatened other neighboring
countries as well
in september 1980 iraq under the rule of
dictator saddam hussein
invaded iran he was hoping to stop the
iranian revolution
gain power and annex some of iran's oil
reserves
but they didn't get far the war bogged
down into a stalemate complete with
trench warfare chemical weapons and
heavy civilian casualties
when iran started winning the saudis
panicked and came to iraq's rescue
they provided money weapons and
logistical help and so it becomes
critical to the saudis
that they build up iraq and build it up
into a wall
that can hold back the iranian
torrent that they have unleashed the
saudi help allowed iraq to fight until
1988.
by then nearly a million people had died
the iranians largely blamed the saudis
for the war and the feud escalated
fast forward 15 years and iraq again
became the scene of a proxy war
in 2003 the us invaded iraq and
overthrew saddam hussein
neither saudi arabia or iran wanted this
to happen since iraq had been acting as
a buffer between them
but problems arose when the u.s
struggled to replace saddam the united
states has
no idea what it's doing in iraq after
2003
and it makes one mistake after another
that creates a security vacuum and a
failed state and drives iraq into
all-out civil war
without a government armed militias took
control of iraq splintering the
population
sunni and shia militias suddenly sprang
up all over the country
many were radical islamist groups who
saw an opportunity to gain power amidst
the chaos
these militias were ready-made proxies
for saudi arabia and iran
and they both seized the opportunity to
try and gain power
the saudis started sending money and
weapons to the sunni militias and iran
the shia
iraq was suddenly a proxy war with saudi
arabia and iran supporting opposing
sides
that trend continued into the arab
spring a series of anti-monarchy
pro-democracy protests that swept
through the middle east in 2011
and this had very different consequences
for saudi arabia and iran
that is terrifying to the saudis who are
the
ultimate status quo power they want the
region stable
and they don't want anybody rising up
and
overthrowing a sclerotic autocratic
government
for fear that it might inspire their own
people to do the same
the iranians are the ultimate
anti-status quo
power they have been trying for decades
to overturn the regional order
each country threw their weight behind
different groups all over the middle
east
just like in iraq the saudis began
supporting sunni groups and governments
while iran helped shia groups rise up
against them
for example in tunisia the saudis backed
a dictator while the iranians stoked
protests
in bahrain iran supported shia leaders
seeking to overthrow the government
saudi arabia in turn sent troops to help
quash the unrest
both got involved in libya lebanon and
morocco as well
as saudi arabia and iran put more and
more pressure on these countries
they began to collapse now the feud has
gone a step further
with both countries deploying their own
militaries in yemen the saudi military
is on the ground helping the central
government
they are fighting the rebels called the
houthis who are an iranian proxy group
and the reverse is happening in syria
the iranian military is fighting side by
side with militias
some of them extremist groups like
hezbollah in support of dictator bashar
al-assad
they are fighting rebel sunni groups who
are saudi proxies
the more civil wars that broke out in
the middle east the more saudi arabia
and iran became involved
neither the government of saudi arabia
nor the government of iran
are looking for a fight but the problem
is that these civil wars
create circumstances that no one could
have predicted
both the iranians and the saudis feel
their vital national interests are
threatened are in jeopardy
because of different things going on in
these civil wars
things that they blame each other for
now the cold war is drawing in other
countries the saudi government is
threatening qatar
a tiny gulf state that was developing
ties with iran meanwhile in syria and
iraq
the terrorist group isis is nearing
defeat and both the saudis and iranians
are angling to take control of that
territory
it's a cold war that's becoming
incredibly unpredictable as the middle
east continues to destabilize
it's hard to say how far these countries
will go
you